est-ce qui a besoin d'expliquer quoi que
ce soit avant les histoires trois
nouvelles histoires bien évidemment avec
des mécaniques différente de d'habitude
mais certaines vous vous rappelez
certaines histoires qu'on a déjà raconté
voilà aujourd'hui il va y avoir de la
tentative de kidnapping de l'usurpation
d'identité et de l'intrusion à domicile
tout ce qu'on aime dans ces vidéos
seraient d'horreur tout d'abord on
commence avec l'histoire de michel mais
celle expliquer son histoire a lieu
comme celle d'après d'ailleurs à une
époque où il n'y a pas encore de
téléphone portable et internet
et mine de rien internet et les
téléphones portables c'est bien cool
pour quand il t'arrive une galère pour
quand tu tombes sur quelqu'un qui veut
du mal bref à l'époque michel c'est une
jeune maman qui a la trentaine elle
emmène ses enfants chez le pédiatre
elle met donc deux de ses trois enfants
dans la voiture et elle fait une heure
de route pour aller chez son pédiatre
c'était un cabinet à ces nouveaux en
gros il venait de construire un bâtiment
sur un nouvel embranchement de route
donc c'était un endroit assez isolé ça
sent pas bon vous savez en arrivant sur
place il ya déjà quatre ou cinq voitures
sur le parking et michel se gare sur la
place la plus proche de la porte
d'entrée du bâtiment elle détache ses
deux enfants de leur siège auto et les
emmène du coup dans le bâtiment et puis
elle va attendre à peu près une heure
avant qu'enfin le médecin vienne la
chercher on arrive à la fin de la
consultation michel paye tout se passe
très bien et elle retourne à sa voiture
et c'est là que les emmerdes commencent
mais chez elle installe ses deux enfants
dans la voiture elle s'assoit sur le
siège du conducteur elle tourne la clé
de la voiture sauf que la voiture
démarre pas dans cette situation soit et
mécaniciens et tu résout le problème toi
même ce qui n'est pas du tout le cas de
michel soit tu sors ton portable et
appelle un dépanneur ce qui n'est pas du
tout le cas de michel non plus car
rappelez vous c'était il ya des dizaines
d'années et n'avait pas de téléphone
portable
elle va donc des tâches et ses deux
enfants et leur prendre avec elle pour
retourner dans le bâtiment et emprunter
le téléphone fixe du cabinet elle trouve
le numéro d'un dépanneur elle l'appelle
et lui explique qu'il a un truc à finir
et qui sera pas là avant une heure mais
qui va faire au plus vite mais chez elle
lui donne l'adresse et puis elle
retourne du coup dans sa voiture avec
ses deux enfants
mais le temps passe et après un petit
moment toutes les lumières du bâtiment
du médecin s'éteignent et tous les gens
rejoignent leur voiture et quitte le
parking
à tel point que la voiture de michel se
retrouve à être la dernière voiture
garée sur ce parking pour passer le
temps elle essaye de trouver des petites
activités dans la voiture elle essaie de
donner des collations à ses enfants elle
veille à ce qu'ils aient pas trop chaud
etc bref une maman modèle et bonne
nouvelle le dépanneur arrive beaucoup
plus tôt prévu puisque après 40 minutes
à peine après le coup de fil qu'une
camionnette arrive sur le parking un
homme descend de la voiture souriant à
michel et soulève le capot elle va
pouvoir rejoindre son domicile avec ses
enfants bref elle est refaite mais
michel attend le moment où enfin le
dépanneur va lui dire essayer de
démarrer mais ce moment n'arrive pas le
gars est là la tête dans son capot
depuis plusieurs minutes et il dit rien
à plusieurs reprises le dépanneur
propose à michel de venir voir ce qu'il
est en train de faire sous le capot pour
qu'elle comprenne qu'elle était problème
est qu'elle puisse régler ça elle même
la prochaine fois que ça lui arrive
proposition que michel refuse en
souriant en expliquant moi je suis pas
mécanicien je vais rien comprendre
6 à murray arrive je rappellerai de
nouveau un dépanneur après un moment
michel elle réalise que le gars il
al'air frustré du fait qu'elle ne
veuille pas sortir de la voiture pour
aller voir ce qui fait sous le capot et
c'est à peu près à ce moment là qu'un
pick-up débarque sur le parking et se
gare proche de la voiture de michel et
d'un coup le gentil mec qui réparer la
voiture de michel ferme brusquement le
capot court vers sa camionnette là
démarre et se casse
michel elle est confuse et elle est un
peu angoissée elle comprend pas trop ce
qui vient de se passer pourquoi le
dépanneur d'un coup l'abandonnent elle
avec ses deux enfants seuls sur un
parking alors qu'il fait nuit
le conducteur du pick-up ouvre sa
portière décent et s'approche de la
voiture de michel et la première chose
qui va faire c'est s'excuser de son
retard avant de pointer du doigt la
route et lui demander qui était l'homme
qui venait de partir si soudainement
mais chez elle elle a une réaction
marrante à ce moment là c'est elle et
pas du tout dans le stress elle est
soulagée elle lui sourit elle lui dit ah
bah je croyais que c'était voué à
commença à à michel comte franz à
l'homme qui est en face de michel c'est
le vrai dépanneur mais aucun des deux
réalisent la gravité de la chose
à ce moment précis le vrai dépanneur va
donc levé le capot de la voiture de
michel et commencé à inspecter le
problème quelques secondes plus tard
michel est tourné vers sa banquette
arrière parce qu'elle est en train de
s'occuper de ses enfants et le dépanneur
se présente à sa fenêtre avec un objet
dans sa main une sorte de gros poignard
elle lui demande donc mais pourquoi vous
montrer ça vous le vous sortez sad où
est le vrai dépanneur lui dit qu'il
vient de trouver ça sous son capot
les deux vont alors devenir un peu pâle
et réaliser que cet objet n'était pas
dans le bloc moteur avant que l'homme
qui est venu quelques minutes plus tôt
fasse semblant de réparer la voiture de
michel
il lui dit alors madame je sais pas ce
qu'elle est arrivée ici mais en tout cas
je suis content d'être arrivé à temps
avant que ça arrive
puis dépanneur retourne dans son pick up
pour le démarrer et fait signe à michel
de démarrer aussi son véhicule et bingo
la voiture démarre
michel va alors payer la facture du
dépanneur et sous les conseils de ce
dernier elle va une fois rentrée chez
elle appelé la police pour leur
expliquer ce qui vient de se passer
la police va prendre soin d'écouter ce
qu'elle a à leur dire et il lui explique
qu'elle a eu beaucoup de chance même si
elle leur a proposé de leur amener
l'objet il lui explique écoutez ce sera
classée sans suite donc prenez soin de
vous soyez vigilante et puis au courage
et en vrai effectivement il pouvait pas
faire grand-chose mais donc michel a
failli clairement se faire buter par un
gars qui a prétendu être son dépanneur
alors qu'ils l'étaient pas et surtout
comment ce gars est arrivé au bon moment
au bon endroit c'est dingue
bref faites attention au dépanneur
passion à l'histoire de kenza histoire
qu'elle a appelée crazy world
cette histoire a eu lieu quand elle
était enfant elle avait 7 ans et c'était
avant même l'arrivée d'internet qu'un
deuil sa mère venait d'emménager dans
une grande maison blanche en face d'une
garderie elle explique que c'était la
plus belle des maisons dans laquelle
elle et sa mère avait pu vivre
étant donné que sa mère avait toujours
du mal à boucler les fins de mois et que
son père poursuivre et ses rêves
d'artistes et verser une pension mais
une pension modeste parce qu'il avait
très peu de moyens à l'époque kenza elle
est hyper contente parce qu'elle a tout
le rez-de-chaussée de la maison pour
elle sa mère elle à tous les étages du
dessus et kenza elle est contente parce
qu'elle habite vraiment en phase de la
garderie ce qui nous intéresse c'est le
voisin de gauche de kenza un monsieur
qui s'appelle ron ron c'est un homme qui
a la quarantaine à savoir dix ans de
plus que la maman de kenza bref comment
kenza et sa mère ont rencontré ron pour
la première fois et ben après midi après
le retour de kenza de la garderie il est
apparu dans la cour de leur maison et
immédiatement la mère de kenza le trouve
chez le rhône avait l'air beaucoup trop
content de vivre à côté d'une mère
célibataire qui vit avec sa fille et qui
est dans le besoin financièrement plus
tard la maman de kenza expliquera même
qu'elle pensait que ron avait eu un coup
de coeur sur elle et qu'en fait il
d'assez d'user quoi bref on fait donc
son apparition dans la cour de la maison
et y vient pour offrir un cadeau la
maman de kenza un cadeau qui est un
vieux médailles avec à l'intérieur une
photo de kenza ce médaillon y ressemble
fortement à une antiquité et c'est
plutôt logique puisque ronny les
antiquaires la photo en revanche est
très troublante puisqu'il s'agit d'une
photo de kenza qui n'a ni été prise par
sa mère ni par elle-même
ce qui veut donc dire que ron a pris en
photo kenza avec à l'époque un 35 mm
y'avait pas d'appareil numérique avant
d'en mettre une dans ce fameux médaillon
qu'il offre à la maman kenza s'écrit pis
y'a rien de normal hockey la mère de
kenza dans un premier temps refusé
fermement le cadeau en expliquant attend
mec t'as pris des photos de ma fille à
son insu pendant qu'elle jouait dans la
cour
ça dégage sauf que ron d'un coup devient
extrêmement triste et il semble
inconsolable
du coup la vente kenza elle culpabilise
et au final elle accepte le médaillon à
contrecoeur bien entendu email
quelques semaines plus tard ron fait de
nouveau son apparition dans la cour y
sonne au portail de kenza et de sa maman
et cette fois il vient leur offrir une
chaîne stéréo et apparemment ils leur
offrent un des modèles les plus chers
qui existe comme pour la première fois
la maman de kenza refuse le cadeau mais
ron la supplie d'accepter le cadeau et
après plusieurs minutes de discussion
elle cède quelques jours plus tard
ronson de nouveau chez elle et cette
fois il vient leur offrir un appareil
photo un appareil photo professionnel
serait chaud l'appareil avec lequel il a
pris des photos de keynes a cette fois
ci la maman de kenza en a marre elle
remet les pendules à l'heure elle lui
dit écoute ton appareil photo
professionnel
j'en veux pas et maintenant c'est chao à
partir d'os laren n'ai plus jamais allés
sonner chez elle pour leur offrir des
cadeaux
le message de l'armement de kenza est
donc passé mais par conséquent la maman
de kenza elle a un mauvais feeling elle
sait pas de quoi est capable ron et elle
sait pas ce qui va faire pour combler le
fait qu'il peut plus venir lui offrir
des cadeaux du coup elle est vachement
sur ses gardes à chaque fois qu'elles
rentrent du travail
elle interdit à quenza d'aller jouer
dans la cour le temps passe et les
parents de kenza établi un calendrier de
visites puisqu'elle vit avec sa mère est
désormais tous les samedis soirs elle va
aller chez son père pour le voir et
passer un moment avec lui le premier
samedi soir se passe super bien jusqu'au
lendemain quand son père l'a ramène chez
sa mère et qu'il apprend que dans la
nuit quelqu'un est rentré par effraction
dans la maison de kenza et sa maman est
effectivement dans la nuit du samedi au
dimanche la maman de kenza et donc seul
dans la maison
à l'étagé elle entend quelqu'un rentrée
au vélo c'est et fouillé par réflexe
elle a fermé à clé la porte qui permet
d'accéder à l'étagé elle a attendu que
l'intrus parts
heureusement kenza n'était pas là à ce
moment là parce que sinon elle serait
tombée nez à nez avec cet intrus et elle
a en plus pour habitude le samedi soir
de profiter pleinement du système sont
qu'heureux leur a offert est de mettre
la musique forte au rez-de-chaussée
puisque a pas école le lendemain bref
nos trois amis sont donc allé voir la
police ils ont conseillé à la maman de
kenza d'acheter un chien et un fusil de
chasse
c'est une autre époque qu'elle a donc
parlé de l'incident avec son père et
elle en est venue à lui parlé de ron est
le père de kenza c'est un gars qui a
fait 15 ans de boxe il n'a pas du tout
peur des autres il va suivre cette
histoire de très près un certain temps
s'écoule environ deux semaines et kenza
remarque que quand elle va à l'école
ron passe souvent l'après midi près de
la cour mais un jour ron s'arrête devant
la clôture de la cour de la garderie il
propose à quenza qu'ils aillent acheter
une
ensemble et heureusement kenza même à
cette époque elle a été mise en garde à
multiples reprises et par ses parents et
par l'école des signes qui montrent
qu'un adulte ne te veut pas du bien le
coup du allez viens on va acheter une
glace bref tous ces phrases bateau elle
les connaît on lui a expliqué et du coup
à ce moment là face à ron elle a un
déclic et elle comprend que ron n'est
pas juste un inconnu un peu sympa et
bizarre elle comprend qu'il a des idées
derrière la tête d'un coup elle est très
mal à l'aise et elle s'éloigne de la
clôture en dix ans aaron désolé je dois
partir et elle s'en va la récréation se
termine kenza retourne en cours et
environ une heure après elle est appelée
à se rendre dans le bureau du directeur
de l'école ce qui a bien sûr pour effet
de la terrifier elle n'y est jamais allé
avant elle c'est parce qu'elle a fait de
mal donc elle se met à stresser et en
arrivant dans le bureau du directeur
elle voit que son père et sa mère sont
là
kenza comprend que si sa mère et son
père ont dû rentrer du travail pour
aller à l'école dans le bureau du
directeur
c'est qu'il se passe quelque chose et ce
qui s'est passé c'est assez simple ron
est allée dans le bureau du directeur
déclarant qu'il était le père de kenza
et qu'il venait la chercher parce qu'ils
allaient déménager dans un autre état
rien que ça est ce qui a fait foirer le
plan de ron c'est que le papa de kenza
et est très pote avec un autre artiste
qui se trouve être le petit ami de la
professeur d'école de kenza donc la
professeure savait à quoi ressemble est
le vrai père de kenza ils ont donc fait
attendre one en lui disant ok kenza va
venir elle range ses affaires et dit au
revoir à ses camarades sûr qu'en fait
ils ont appelé la police
et c'est pas kenza qui arrivait dans le
bureau c'est les flics au moment où
qu'ils aillent dans le bureau avec ses
parents rhône a déjà été embarqués du
coup par la police
malgré tout le père de kenza veut
prendre zéro risque et donc qu'elle va
aller vivre chez son père pendant
plusieurs semaines au cas où ron ne
serait pas encore derrière les barreaux
le fin mot de l'histoire c'est
qu'apparemment juan vivait avec sa mère
qui est décédée quelques mois avant ces
événements et donc il s'est retrouvé
seul dans cette maison il a grandi dans
un climat pas du tout ça il avait
apparemment un retard de croissance
psychosexuel bref y compter kidnappé
kenza et partir qu'on ne sait pas où
mais partir avec elle est abandonnée
cette maison derrière lui le plus
flippant dans cette histoire c'est qu'en
fait kenza et sa maman s'était trompé sa
mère n'était pas du tout la cible de ron
ron voulait simplement avoir des bons
liens avec la maman de kenza pour
pouvoir la dupe et plus facilement et
accèder à kenza c'était juste un moyen
de contourner ce qui l'empêché
d'atteindre kenza voilà donc il est rien
arrivé à quenza mais à l'époque c'était
un truc qui était assez fréquent en fait
les kidnappings beaucoup plus que
maintenant il y avait beaucoup moins de
moins
1 la loi encadre et beaucoup moins ça il
y avait c'était beaucoup plus dur de
trouver des preuves etc bref on est
quand même à une époque où lou tout ça
ça a bien avancé alors il ya plein de
gars qui s'en sortent et qui restent
impunis mais on n'est pas non plus au
stade on était dans les années 80 où
c'était vraiment chaud quoi si vous avez
des petits frères des petites nièces et
neveux bref des jeunes dans votre
famille et s'était pas leur rappeler
quand un adulte proposé des bonbons
ça dégage quand il veut que tu montes
dans sa voiture ça dégage j'en avais
parlé dans une des anecdotes mais moi ça
m'a vraiment sauvé la vie que ma mère
aime parle de ça quand j'étais plus
jeune j'ai vraiment failli être
kidnappée quoi il ya un gars qui avait
ouvert sa portière il m'avait dit salut
mon petit viens j'ai plein de monde dans
la voiture monte dans la voiture ça
m'est arrivé quoi bref dernière histoire
celle de sacha son histoire est beaucoup
plus courte rassurez vous mais elle est
horrible voilà c'est arrivé quinze ans
avant qu'il la raconte à une époque où
il vivait dans un immeuble au
rez-de-chaussée
sacha avait 15 ans à ce moment là et à
linverse de kenza ils vivent et non pas
avec sa mère mais avec son père et du
coup ils allaient un week-end sur deux
chez sa maman ce jour-là il est minuit
trente la maman de sacha d'or dans sa
chambre lui il est dans le salon devant
la télé et dans le salon il ya deux
fenêtres qui donnent sur la route qui se
trouve à quelques mètres de la maison
s'achève il est dans son meilleur pyjama
il est posé devant la télé et du coin de
l'oeil et voit qu'il ya un mouvement
dans l'une des deux fenêtres
il regarde alors à travers cette fenêtre
et ce qu'ils voient c'est tout
simplement le visage d'un mec collé à la
fenêtre qui le fixe avec un grand
sourire
sacha est paralysée de peur pendant 20
secondes
ils ne bougent pas ils se regardent dans
les yeux avec ce mec qui est là juste de
l'autre côté de sa fenêtre du salon et
d'un coup il part en courant du canapé
direction la chambre de sa mère pour
l'avertir qu'il ya un homme de l'autre
côté de la maison qui le regardent
au moment où sa maman comprend ce que
sacha et c'est lui dire dans la panique
ils entendent tous les deux quelqu'un
essayait d'ouvrir la porte d'entrée tous
deux restent alors immobile pétrifié de
perth où les bruits de cette porte que
quelqu'un essaie désespérément d'ouvrir
et après plusieurs secondes ça s'arrête
sacha et sa mère se regarde dans les
yeux et d'un coup sa mère comprend
quelque chose et elle dit à sacha la
porte de derrière la porte de derrière
était tout le temps ouverte et du coup
la maman de sacha part en courant vers
cette porte pour la fermer à double tour
elle retourne ensuite dans sa chambre
récupérer une batte de base-ball qu'elle
a mis sous son lit en cas de danger
comme la puis elle rejoint sacha elle
lui ordonne d'appeler immédiatement la
police et elle se met face à la porte
arrière la batte de baseball en l'air
sacha expliqué la police au téléphone en
chuchotant que quelqu'un essaie de
rentrer chez lui il donne à la police
son adresse et puis rejoint sa maman
face à la porte après quelques secondes
une ombre
approche de la porte et quelqu'un essaie
de l'ouvrir en appuyant frénétiquement
sur la poignée
cette personne va même donner des coups
de pied dans la porte et hurler de rage
c'est à ce moment là que la mère de
sacha décide de lui mettre un coup de
pression en lui expliquant qu'elle est
une batte de base-ball et que si ce gars
aux rentrées chez elles
elle va le frapper à mort immédiatement
la personne de l'autre côté de la porte
va arrêter de la ruée de coups il va
ensuite se retourner et s'enfuir et
sasha et sa mère vont rester face à la
porte pendant vingt bonnes minutes
toujours la batte de baseball en l'air
le temps que la police arrive
en arrivant sur les lieux la police
constate qu'effectivement les fleurs qui
entoure la maison ont été piétinées ils
vont demander à sacha qui est la seule
personne à avoir vu le visage de l'homme
de l'heure d'écrire pour qu'ils puissent
établir peut-être un portrait robot et
entamé des recherches mais
malheureusement leur recherche vous rien
donné et sasha et la police est la maman
de sacha non plus jamais entendu parler
de ce mec
un an plus tard sa mère emménager
ailleurs par peur que ce gars reviennent
et sasha lui fit carrément dans un autre
pays avec sa femme alors c'est pas liées
à cet incident assez juste les aléas de
la vie mais voilà ça les a bien marqué
et c'est ça en fait qui vous fait que
ces histoires là c'est que même si la
personne s'en sort et qu'il ne lui
arrive rien elle développe des réflexes
et des peurs qu'elle n'avait pas avant
et souvent ça lui pourrit la vie et ça
les amène à emménager ailleurs en fait
et bien voilà c'est la femme de trois
histoires bien bas dans moi stuc de qui
n'appliquent ça me touche vraiment parce
que c'est beaucoup plus fréquent qu'on
ne le pense pas que je faisais dix mois
sa fin il m'arrivait donc ça me sert
medard ça m'a un peu trop mal aussi
et du coup là c'est vraiment horrible
quoi ce procédé pas et le gars qui se
fait passer pour un dépanneur mais en
plus de gars arrivé au bon moment au bon
endroit c'est horrible et puis toujours
ces histoires d'intrusion de coach
inquiets et c'est fou quoi je suis bien
content d'être dans un étage élevé quoi
franchement tous ceux qui vivent au rez
de chaussée la ou en maison et qu'ils
regardent laisserait doha mais bonne
chance mais ça vous regardez la vidéo
j'espère que l'histoire vous ont plu que
vous avez aimé c'est mécanique
je vous et à bientôt portez vous bien
bisous tout le monde
[Musique]